brought to you by PlayStation store
access to the ultimate in games and
entertainment
hello and welcome to the Lobby
gamespot's weekly hangout every Tuesday
at 2 p.m. Pacific right here at
gamespot.com headquarters in San
Francisco which has been overrun by
filthy disgusting game developer people
look at the mother just creeping around
oh we got a couple on our couch H what's
going on my God Arman my good friend
coffee stain Studios developers of are
you not wearing a goat simulator shirt
today this is the Westport Independence
game that we working out oh fantastic
we'll talk to you about that in a second
and Mike bthl another European game
developer we're taking over I know
creator of Thomas Was Alone and of
course volume which we'll be seeing
later this year this year maybe close
we'll see uh put mic on oh you need to
put your mics on apparently we didn't
know yeah see hey guys
profession here we go there's one you've
got one right behind your back we'll add
We'll add subtitles and post don't worry
about it this thing this thing's like a
pre-record right yeah yeah it's live no
no you'd be surprised how often we do we
redo segments for a live show actually
seriously Chris Waters is back hello you
not you're not covered in swine flu
anymore whatever it was I live I went to
Upstate New York in February guess what
happens there you get the flu and it's
terrible uh but I'm great now are you
heading back East for packs at the end
of the week no I'm not neither am I
either are you guys since you're in the
country going yeah I'm going one day
just one day just to kind of duck in
quickly and go Bost exactly yeah uh you
guys come over for GDC uh all the time
uh Chris you were talking to me earlier
about like the sort of what is the
impetus for people to come to GDC
because as far as like the folks who
come to Gamespot are concerned it's kind
of like a light news show but obviously
while you're here like that's surely not
why these gentlemen are here yeah I mean
like we as press it's only been in
recent years that there's really been a
burgeoning sort of scene of demos and
people showing off their games at GDC in
the past it's been sort of like it it is
for game developers we are not game
developers like we what we can get out
of it is only sort of tangential but I'm
curious know like what do you guys get
out of it I mean obviously now showing
your game is is one of the impetuses for
coming but like do you sort of line up
like things you want to hear about
people you want to hear talk like is
this a resource for you professionally
are you networking sort of like what's
the whole are you just like getting
drunk and going to parties it's drinking
isn't it yeah it's primarily drinking
like what's why why do you come to GDC
it's kind of a thing where you know you
we're supposed to be at show off go
simulator on Xbox and our new game that
we're publishing but uh uh you know
there's a lot a lot of a lot of drinking
and a lot of partying there you there
you go there you go put your mic on good
that's nice uh yeah so obviously you
guys are shopping around your games um
is there any like talks you've been to
at all is there any like you look down
through the like list of panels and go
you know what actually I need to see
that cuz some of the most interesting
stuff I've seen at GDC has have been
just panels of people that I've just
like I've had an air to spare and I've
gone in yeah so I mean that's how
generally how I do I don't plan out too
much cuz frankly like my schedule is
just like packed with the stuff I'm here
to do like work-wise like it's kind of
you know I I have to go and do this
press thing or I have to go and meet
this person to talk about this platform
whatever um but yeah for me like the
nice bit is oh I've got half an hour
that's exciting I'll like run excitedly
and find the first thing I can um but
yeah they're cool I not the only talk
I've been to so far is one I was on oh
really and that was middling was it all
right I was okay I was a little rush my
slides didn't work so I got to spend uh
I got to spend like half an hour
basically apologizing well apparently
John kx's talk which is on today
tomorrow I think maybe tomorrow he's got
like a 2 and a half hour presentation
and then today he decided he wasn't
actually going to use slides so it's
just going to be John car talking for
two and a half hours but of all the
people to listen to for two and a half
hours like oh yeah apparently they put
him just before lunchtime so they could
run over because they reckon he's not
going to stay within his slot as well uh
have you seen any talks in previous
years that you were interest that you
like still remember to this day I'm
trying to think the ones that are really
inspiring
I'm actually I'm drawing blank how about
you I like there's there's so much cool
talks to go to but I I have a problem
like sitting down for an hour right I
you know I I usually when I'm at home I
play a game and I watch something on TV
and I sometimes have my cell phone up
too so I can watch Twitter and I can I
can sit I can sit for like five or 10
minutes but then I'm like you know too
much got got to do something so uh you
guys are both based in Europe uh you're
still based in London Mike that's right
uh uh you're based in Mainland you're in
Sweden Sweden yeah yeah so
you know you're kind of remote in your
own way like I'm sure there's a Swedish
development Community there's obviously
a lot going on in London remote from
America D you've changed you used to you
used to think that the UK was all right
that used to be country Irish boy with
my own the Waterford games development
Community was never that hot H what's it
like then like is there an element of
this where you're like you're meeting up
with people who you've you've talked to
a lot like online or collaborative
massive that's the best part of it it's
just like yeah especially like you know
I spend a bit of time on Twitter so I've
got a load of mates who are yeah online
friends and yeah it's just nice to
actually be able to see them like two or
three times a year like we see each
other at this game's come and then it's
enough that's enough for me yeah like
there's yeah like there there's people
who I want to see more than that but
most of them it's like yeah you you get
through the week I'm sure they feel same
about me and you're like yeah okay you
can go back to where you live and I'll
go back to where I live and we'll see
each other again soon I don't mean that
um but yeah no it's it's lovely it's
it's cool seeing those those old friends
and those old faces and catching up and
playing each other's games and yeah to
the bar is it mostly social or do you
feel like you're sort of getting like
even if it's not like sitting down going
to a talk and like learning about
something specific do you think you're
like gaining experience from what other
people are creating oh yeah well it's I
think it bring everyone comes together
and yeah shares shares and I think I
think the stuff that's really useful is
the I think a lot of people say this is
is it's not so much always the talks but
it's the conversation you have outside a
pub at 3:00 in the morning with the like
you know with maybe a developer a bit
more experienced than you or someone
who's released a game on a platform
you're thinking of doing and they're
like right these are the five things you
need to make sure you do this way and
it's like that's the value like that
genuinely that that 20 minute
conversation with someone far cleverer
than me was worth the flight like that
was that set me up um and I've already
had like three of those conversations in
like two days so I'm I'm feeling very
good about the trip uh you guys were
both at the mix last night uh just down
the road at the omm buildings um what
was that like uh you've been have you
been to a couple of them at this stage
no no that was my first yeah it was cool
does the Indie scene like seem different
to you than what it did like two or 3
years ago cuz I was kind of there was a
time I guess where like a lot of those
games you kind of had they looked small
they looked like oh this is being made
by a small team but there were so many
games last night there and also on the
Gamespot stream we had yesterday um that
just didn't look like what you know my
silly non-developer mind would say Indie
gam yeah like definitely like a couple
of years ago uh we we didn't have as
many like High quality uh indie games
like especially now with unity and
Unreal Engine you see a lot of really
really cool stuff uh just made by by
Indie developers I think as well it's a
generational thing and like it's
computers so the generations are like
weekly but like the the thing I think I
think what you're seeing there at event
like the mix and it was fun walking
around is you're seeing like the the
girl working in her spare time like you
know two hours a week kind of just
making something uh in her bedroom and
then next to them you're seeing you know
the person who brought out a game three
years ago did really well and they've
put all the money into this thing
hopefully it'll sell otherwise they're
in trouble kind of thing and then and
everyone in between and and that's in
the Indie as a term is starting to
stretch because so many Indies have
actually had some kind of financial
success and and the budget allows them
to bring in more collaborators and you
get you know bigger bigger projects so
it's I think that's exciting um I it
feel it almost feels like we're
rebuilding a new game industry as like
our little bubble is kind of expanding
and it's kind of taking in different
people and doing different things but it
seems like the other one is Contracting
sometimes as well like Chris we think of
the some of the AAA games that we cover
or you know there's a reason why they
just say triaa now and then Indie
because that whole middle section seems
to be just kind of like yeah I mean
entire sort of middle the road
Publishers that like make a big game and
you know have a sizable budget but that
has proven to be not like the most
financially viable over the past years
and that's definitely changed the scene
it's and it's interesting to to hear
talk about sort of the progression of
the Indie development scene at GDC I
imagine you guys now you know if you're
you know couple years ago you're sort of
looking to network but now are you
having people like seek you out as like
the guys who have like these guys have
shipped successful games like hey can
you give me this tip or that like I'm
never going to get bored of of someone I
don't know walking up to me and asking
me to fist bump with them that's never
that's amazing like it probably will
last about six more months um and then
will never happen again um by volume um
but the uh but but it's it's kind of
it's It's a uh it's it's a weird thing
it's it's but that cycle happens and
it's it's fun watching that happen I I I
don't I guess it's hard to kind of tell
when you're at the epicenter of it but I
love watching it happen to other people
so I love like when you'll when they'll
when you'll like you'll know some guy
that you had breakfast with two years
ago and they were talking to you about
their weird idea and then you're like
you you meet them at event like this and
it's like oh you're now you're now the
guy who made that game it's like taken
over and everyone's obsessed with and
it's like I remember when you know I
bought you some pancakes because you
left your rollet at home that's amazing
I remember when we had a burger and the
Lord Nelson in lond in corner from work
CH or like that was how long ago is that
Alexander when we did like a Skype
interview for that video I made and now
dude's like antichamber game me worked
on for like two decades is ended up like
being really successful and it happens
it's great do you think just you touched
on a point just the last point with this
you touched on something about the
technology you're using Unity 5 right on
volume I'm I'm us yeah I am using Unity
5 a bet Unity okay so is that like uh do
you think like like the progression of
stuff like Unity has really helped like
like enable developers who might have
otherwise had the tools to do it to like
make bigger and better games I think I
think the engines are great because what
the engines have done is they've um
they've they've basically geographically
moved the um the talent to this is such
an old trailer by the way this is
definitely not Unity this is barely
Unity 4 um but um yeah so I think what's
happened is the talent is is all the all
these amazing uh programmers and
Engineers that make games work like
literally make the engines they run have
all gone to these big companies like
Unity like unreal and their genius is
then being distributed in a way that
allows all of us idiots to make stuff um
and yeah just jump enormous hurdles like
I I've worked in games now for about
eight years and I remember the one the
example I always use is my first job for
like six months was making nav meshes
nav meshes it's boring but it's
basically it's the way in which it's
basic trying think how say basically
it's when an enemy runs around a level
it's the data that tells the enemy where
they can and can't go right um and that
was my first job and I used to be I was
quite fast so I could do a room in a day
and it took like you know it's very
laborious job that's now in unity that's
a I think a .27 millisecond process you
can press a button and it just does that
was my first job
too if you heard of the game sanctum
that was like the coffee first game
before the game with a goat in it and
those so that was like my first I had a
summer job and I was supposed to like do
the nav mesh and Sh it's like it's a
horrible it's kind of like you know
picking weeds when you're for like one
step down from placing crates in the
first
person it's like it's like the manual
labor of the gaming industry which now
doesn't exist and today like in 4 you
just press a button and it's like it's
done and it's but that's also like you
know you're like we actually do it in we
do it in volume we do it in at run time
so when you're editing levels in the
game you press a button and it just make
automatically makes an nav mesh and it's
like oh my goodness but you know OB I'm
quite glad I got my first job because it
led to the new ones but it's it's so
exciting and it's such a great
opportunity for people people starting
to make games now I imagine I'm I'm sure
that when I started eight years ago
there were people who started 16 years
ago like oh my God that guy doesn't know
he's born look at how quick he can make
a nav mesh you know I used have to type
those numbers in by hand um and so
what's the new nav mesh what's the I
mean just robots are taking all the
young Developer jobs now I think I think
the next one that I'd love to see um
someone like Unity really tackle um
Unity or unreal is ai ai is the thing
that I think is a stumbling B there's a
reason that a lot of Indie Games either
are you know a character moving around a
space with no enemies or kind of uh or
enemies you know that are very kind of
straightforward logically and it's
because AI is really hard getting and
and getting AI that that's fun is hard
you know making an AI That's efficient
is actually very easy
um it's making it inefficient in a way
that's entertaining um so so I think uh
I think that's that's a challenge I'd
love to see the engin take on because I
think if you can come up with some kind
of centralized and there's a few things
that they're playing with but kind some
kind of centralized AI solution uh
that's going to lead to such a big jump
in what we can do excellent for me it
would be like uh if you'd have a bot
that would just uh all the people that
ask you when the Xbox Port is coming
when when the when the Android port is
like why is it crashing like like some
bot that tells people just to like shut
up you're talking you're talking but all
I hear is wow wow wow my game is really
successful like it's hard to feel sorry
for you to be
honest well you guys solved the AI
problem with go simulator by just not
having yeah it doesn't matter [__]
people that just fall over when you hit
them yeah perfect uh stick around guys
thank you so much for talking to us
about all that uh but we're since you're
here and since there's actual video game
and news happening here at GDC as well
we decided stick around and we'll we'll
we'll have you guys talk about some
stuff that's broken today we'll be back
in a second when we're talking about
mear solid 5es release date thanks for
that IGN by the way H we'll be back in a
second as a trailer for white night in
the
meantime I was
lost my mind didn't belong to me
anymore trapped in the tumult of the
accident
where am
I
no oh can't
be
no
melar Solid
5 the phantom pain that's coming out
this year we didn't know when it was
going to come out and then some I don't
know some some Italian ass video on IGN
popped up uh this morning for a little
bit somebody on Gaff spotted it as they
always tend to do and now we know
apparently September 1st is when M solid
five grand zeros Chris is noing as cuz
you don't like M so so overrated I don't
know people get so excited about it I'm
so not into it I don't know yeah you
better
yourself yeah you you you're not a Met
fan either right no I haven't played it
like I I want I wanted a Play Station
when I was a kid and my parents told me
to shut up and go outside and play so I
I feel I feel like me and Dany should
just have a chat about this they're like
go go outside and play with the goats H
Mike I I'm going to take a guess based
on what volume looks like that perhaps
you're a fan of metal G sols I've never
play no no
I there is a slight visual similarity
it's been pointed out to me every kind
of 10 minutes on Twitter it's fun um
yeah no it's realit and in real life you
taking the taking it um yeah no it's
cool I'm I'm excited obviously I'm a big
malale gear fan I I and was the first of
September so I can I can exclusively
confirm that that volume will not be out
in September 2015 uh it'll it'll that's
a month that we'll be avoiding is that
something you think like because you
know with the sort of the scale and the
different markets that people are buying
games now is that still something that
you try and stay away from a big release
like that lots of schools of thought so
like we so Thomas Was Alone for example
came out the same day as Call of Duty
right so there's this thing um it's with
TV scheduling like they were programing
counter programing exactly so if there's
a big sports game on you'll put on a
romantic comedy because you figure the
audiences are different you're giving
something for for each audience but the
um but yeah so with with like another
any other franchise I would probably be
like yeah they're cool they're different
audience it's cool but no I'm I'm trying
to launch a stealth franchise I'm going
to do on a different day to uh to uh to
Mr Mr hideio kima's Game do you go well
beforehand and how many weeks do you
give for but do you give the month
clearance afterwards because it's
supposed to be this massive sprawling
open world the answer to your game is I
check the bug list when I get home from
right find out but uh but yeah so it's
it's it's cool I'm I'm yeah I'm super
excited I Mel gear yeah it'll be a it'll
be I'll take a weekend off and work my
way through well I don't know how big it
is it looks massive so it might be more
than the weekend did you play much
ground zeros at all cuz I know Danny you
were super into that I really
Z I didn't I like those GES to replay
levels so like it was completely
perfectly down my alley like I used to
love playing games like project IGI and
like doing the same level over and over
I know right project I'm going in or
like Rainbow Six like I'd play like
Rogue spear levels over that's how it
feels and that's what's interesting
about it is it has gone into this kind
of more kind of generalist like
smart like it's it's a it's not just
stealth anymore it's it's this kind of
like SAS simulator kind of thing you're
kind of you're you're you're you're
using the weaponry and you're using the
environment AC it's it's cool it's it's
fun I did for a for a rival Outlet I did
a really interesting interview where it
was me and uh one of the designers from
that G from from the Well from both of
the new M gear um and just just hearing
how he talked about it and what their
goals were was just fascinating like the
the the scale of um interaction
possibilities and to be fair like ground
zeros you could see it in there that was
that was you could tackle that a host of
different ways I don't think it's a I
don't think it was an accident that it
was so short that people had to replay
it because I think through the replay
you realize oh actually I could have
done all these different things um so
I'm excited to see that in a in a big
game context especially with all the
extra cardboard boxes with ladies
painted on them that they're bringing
into phantom pain I mean it's just what
was really lacking from I I I do
remember yeah I remember because I was
on stage at Gamescom um for Sony and we
were so I watched the the the box
trailer like about 20 times one day cuz
obviously you're looping through in the
rehearsals and stuff I was just glad
they didn't do like a whole presentation
where all they did was play those [__]
up tapes from Grand zeros over and over
and over again uh yeah I don't know some
of that as much as I love that series
there are some little things in there a
little bit creepy H but there you go
September 1st is when H volume will not
be coming out exclusive here on
gamespot.com uh gentlemen thank you very
much for coming on the show today we're
going to mix it up we got a bunch of
other developers hanging out here
Alexander Bruce and Brad M are going to
come on next uh but before we send you
on your Merry ways please tell us about
your video games volume what's coming
out on when volume is out at another
date of September the 1st for uh
Playstation 4 and Vita first and then a
month later we take it to uh PC and mac
and yeah we're we're we're getting
really close now and it feels good I'm
happy I'm excited excellent you sir yeah
we're working on releasing go simulator
on Xbox uh the most ridiculous sentence
ever heard of my life so hopefully you
know people asking when it's going to be
out I know like when it stops crashing
it's going to be out hopefully this
spring uh be great uh but you know what
if if I tell people a date and we have
to push it forth they're going to burn
down my house so we'll probably tell you
guys later in a couple of weeks May is
it going to have the MMO stuff in it and
all that or uh probably not at the start
but maybe in the future excellent right
now we're just trying to like Cal we're
just trying to get it to run right now
and you're also uh publishing a game
about ethics and journalism tell me
about that b boy
so we're we're publishing game called
the Westport Independence which is a
game where uh you run a newspaper in a
uh uh in a totalitarian state uh so it's
kind of a censorship simulator and it
has nothing to do with what you think
has to do
yesterday's yeah actually when we
announced it I had like a lot of eggs on
Twitter were telling me like it's really
good that you're making finally
someone's addressing these issues and uh
no it was it's been in works there's
like actually two two guys in Sweden
that been working with it for for years
now uh so no it's coming close to
release sometime this year wonderful
looks super interesting saw you guys
playing on the mix last night uh yeah
looking forward to seeing more of that
so thank you very much gentlemen for
coming on really appreciate your time
enjoy the rest of GC sure bump outside
some Pua 3 in the morning as it tends to
happen we'll be back in a second H we're
going to talk about some of the best
games of GDC and virtual reality and a
bunch more first of all here is a
trailer Ry three it don't made another
one let's check it
out
Heroes I won't be around for much
longer
he
at last there will be fish STW for
dinner
hello welcome back to the lobby we're
here with some other fantastically
beautiful and handsome developers Mr
Alexander Bruce creator of antichamber
how are you doing my friend I'm
excellent uh and Brad mure of course
massive chalice great to be back how are
you doing I'm doing great you guys
enjoying GDC yeah it's an enjoyable
thing man every time always especially
for you this guy had to travel halfway
across the world to get here you
just a couple
yeah it's cool just happened how was the
mix last night you were you were at that
showing off some massive chalice yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was it was super cool
I'd never been to it before it was like
some uh some indie dudes put it on and
they borrow the IGN office and like they
just rip up the whole IG floor and just
put all these like uh Indie stations up
and it's got an indie vibe to it too
it's like everybody's walking around
it's just like a free Fruit it feels
like a fret party okay I guess everybody
there's kegs everywhere and everybody's
walking around with beer and it's just
like it's like a fret party with video
games i' never used a beer keg before so
we don't we just have what we just have
pints in just pour them like that that's
not a thing I instructed no fewer than
three people how to use a keg that they
British Irish I did that's hilarious
because I actually went over to get I
think it was beer number two because I
was being responsible and uh I I hit the
lever on is it a lever sure I hit the
lever and just foam just foam it felt
like there was you know an 18-year-old
showing their game or something there
and hit just like just really gone to
town in that thing and it was it was
absurd uh I had you VAT on to talk about
games uh that you saw at GDC 2015
because every time I go to an event
Alexander has played everything and then
I can just ask him what the [__] I
should play that's good I'm going to
learn something sitting here cuz I you
know no you're
not normally normally I do that because
when you meet me at events like packs
and stuff I've helped judge for the Mega
booth and pick different things out I
did none of that for GDC this year so
now I'm here like I don't know I'm going
to discover everything the same as
everyone else I'm looking for the other
Alexander Bruce that can just tell me
what to play well I was thinking maybe
it might be briad cuz you were after mix
last night know yeah all you were doing
was trying to crank beer and play
Massive J that's all I wanted to do I
mean I really enjoy like showing the
game it felt like it felt like a 4our
slice of packs or something where you're
just like you know your booth is like
one Monitor and you're just like kind of
tied to it and you're trying to get
people to play it and talk to them about
it while they're playing it and stuff
give them the sort of like elevator
pitch over and over whatever just yeah
you're just hanging out show video games
man um but all I wanted to do was just
like walk around just like do and I like
some of the other guys on the team were
there so it was nice that I could like
let them kind of show it off and then I
was like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna make a
lap and like see what is going on I
played this game called Hugh I've heard
about this but I actually missed that
last night this is um this is a really
stupid story there was a guy that came
up to check out Master CH he was like oh
yeah whatever uh and then he's like he's
like oh you got to see Hugh you got to
see Hugh it's yeah I was like I was like
oh I've never met Hugh you and he was
like he was like oh yeah he was right
over there okay cool so I like over
there and I'm like I'm like I'm like hey
uh this guy told me I should I should
meet Hugh and they're like oh it's right
here and they like show me a screen and
I'm like what the [__] like what is
happening and they're like like oh it's
a video game it's h u e oh right like
theor and I got it and it yeah okay but
you it was a cool yeah it was a cool
little like uh Indie platformer where
you use the right stick to change the
change the background color all right
and then uh based on the what color the
background is um certain objects will be
like uh they'll disappear because
they're like that exact color and they
just like go away and then it's so you
know you just use that to solve puzzles
a little Puzzler cool so I got to play
that I think that's about uh that's
about it that's about all I got to play
which is sort of sad ni just talk to
Alexander for the next while then there
is one game that I will pimp and it's
not based on having played it recently
I've last played this a couple of years
ago and it was aw awesome at the time
and now it's one of the igf games it's
called memory of a broken Dimension okay
I can't really describe what the hell's
going on it's a first person game with
the most crazy abstract obscured visual
style I've ever seen down your roof
absolutely down my RO is that the one
that's like super staticky that sort of
experimental gameplay and you like sort
of line up the perspective in first
person and then it like snaps and then
there's like a ramp and you're like what
is the guy showed it and it was like it
was so dark when he showed it on the
screen they had to like dim the lights
down and you're like what it just looks
like you're seeing a bunch of dots as
he's like it was super weird but he
that's so great that he like has taken
that game all over completion that's so
so like some of the things it's like you
know he can't he I think he used to be
like a real hacking background this one
this one try to tell me what the [__] is
going on in this game that's the game is
messed up and he was showing it and
you're like that just looks busted no
this is the game busted but this is the
game and it's awesome like trying to
work out what the hell is going on so
are you moving around like first person
style like wasad with a mouse and trying
to like just find some sort of clarity
or yeah and then you've also got like I
don't know if this is still in there but
it used to be like hacking mechanisms
where you're like contacting off radio
signals and you're just like at a
command line trying to work out how the
[__] anything in the game
works it's right up my alley I love it
excellent uh makes me feel weird one of
the things one of the sort of uh the gr
we're always looking for themes in GDC
and all these different years and I
guess we haven't seen all of it just yet
but virtual reality has been like the
sort of the drum that's been getting
loud and louder as people have been
banging it for the past couple years um
this is a year that like we're seeing
the HDC softw valve um there's a bunch
of other uh companies getting involved
in it obviously Morpheus and Oculus
Alexander is somebody who's made like a
firsters game about sending people into
like bizarre like unnatural spaces what
do you think about the revolution in in
virtual reality are you a Believer or do
you think there's a lot of work to be
done people people would think that I
would be a believer like I walked in
here and Brad was like I I was like I
was like you love this what love you're
like the target market
like em told me this and like no I'm
like the hardest sell ever you know it's
like everyone is like oh my God this is
the future now and I'm like these are
all the issues in it you know yes it's
the future in like 10 years and like oh
but can't you see and I'm like no yes I
can see all of the issues that you're
not talking about you know I want I
desperately wanted to be cool but every
time I put it on I'm just like oh my God
what type of stuff stands out to you as
like as that just breaks your emmersion
or makes it feel like it's not working
everything so many so many things so
like you get things like you know there
was there was all of this talk about
presence and like you know people you
actually feel like you're there and you
you you know you've got a demo where
there's this ledge and you're in this
room and some people they get vertigo
you know and I look at that and the
first thing I do is I take a step
forwards and I'm like well I'm just
floating in the air like yeah emerg and
gone you know and then you get another
one it's like here we've realistically
rendered the current room that you're in
so I go to reach for a door handle I'm
like well I have no hands why did you
show me this thing like every time some
to say this is this is reality I'm like
these are all the reasons that it's not
so they fix it by like making you know
things that sense your hands or like
what vales doing with the the no because
there's this is this is a deep Rabbit
Hole of issues you know once you fix one
issue it just reveals all of the other
issues and this is this is The Uncanny
value problem that we had with graphics
for ages you know look at this
screenshot of the most realistic face
you've ever seen and then the moment you
see it animated it's like that looks
like [__] that's a robot you know it
just instantly breaks like agent Smith
in The Matrix and it's like I mean in
that one like like we've kind of climbed
out of it sort of but even at the peak
of it it's like yeah it still just looks
like a fake person like all you need is
one eyeball not to work right still
doesn't it's I'm still not fully buying
that so here for example with like the
interaction stuff you know people would
be like oh we cack your hands and it'll
be all one to one and if I get something
where it's like here's a cup and I go to
grab that cup and I do this yeah my my
my character in game will be holding
this cup and I'm sitting here like this
and my brain is just going to be like
wait that doesn't map one to one like
all all sense of emotion is instantly
gone yeah cuz there's no feedback or
there's no like tactile heptic feedback
yeah so what's the solution to that then
is it can you never create a system
that's replicating the real world laser
tag it's going to be uh destination
gaming you know we're take a warehouse
and uh everybody puts a headset on and
you get a gun and you run around and
shoot each other that's the only thing
that virtual reality is going to do
that's it2 million a gaming is the worst
thing I've ever heard right now uh a
bunch of people who are like you know
people are genuinely excited about this
and that's great it means you get lots
of content there's lots of people that
are working on solving a bunch of these
things some people like to just excuse
these things and be like Oh but yeah but
it'll be cool in 5 years and I'm like
cool so I'll come back in 5 years it's
not cool to me now because of these
issues uh if you want me to be excited
about it now then I need to see games
that are like this is this is virtual
unreality these are all the reasons why
we know it's not going to map to being a
realistic simul so we've specifically
built something that breaks your brain
away from that like you know Brad was
talking you know it's not even like
necessarily the best example it's just a
nice example of the game where you've
got you're a dolphin in a classroom
andair I wish I knew the name of this
game but yeah you're like you're a
dolphin in a classroom and you're taking
a test and you don't know any of the
answers cuz like you're not really a
dolphin you're pretending to be a
dolphin and so the whole game is like
you can't get up from your chair and you
need to try to like look over at the
other dolphins that are like taking
taking the test you need but then you
can't like let the teacher see you like
looking at somebody else's work and it's
like a it's like a cheating in the
classroom simulator but like they they
couch it in this ridiculous thing where
like you're you're [__] dolphin and
like that's just like it's just totally
absurd and like and like yeah Alex
understand well you don't have hands
well who cares it's like you're not a
Dophin you're not Dophin you can't like
put your head through something yeah so
it's like the games that really like
Embrace those limitations and
constraints I think are going to be the
ones that really really stand out in
this generation I mean once you get to
the you know what is this thing called
the Vive is that what you call it oh
yeah yeah the just like all these first
generation like consumer facy things are
probably going to be kind of janky I
don't why are you laughing did I it's
the vi or
whatever the vibe we can all agree is a
real [__] stupid name right I you
know I thought the VA was kind of a bad
name but now it's just now it's just
like nor the Wii U is still a terrible
name that's still bad that hasn't come
around Xbox uh well the virtual reality
game I played at the mix last night
actually was a two-player game and I
think we've talked about it before on
the show but one person had the headset
on and the other person had a binder
keep talking and nobody explodes that's
a good example that's a good example
because it's embracing the isolation
that you've got with this headset and
and you wouldn't want to get up and walk
around and explore this world I think
that's the thing that um is very
difficult for all these is that it's
like virtual reality we're going to put
you into this world and you're going to
explore it it's like well how the hell
am I going to do that like by Mouse
looking and Wasing around it while I do
this like it's just I just don't know um
yeah I I feel like I'm kind of a nay on
this whole virtual reality thing too
this guy it's this guy I just pick up on
his negative Vibes you know I'm just
he's got some good points man I don't
know it feels like when you frame it
like that it does feel like some of the
times we're we're almost like willing it
we're like we we want it to work so bad
that we're just like yeah it's all right
like I know ad in isolation was kind of
like I was like poking around corners
I'm forgetting where the key word was
and all that [__] but I like yeah it's
fine if we all just like hold our hands
together and and chant along it'll be
okay one of the one of the things that
like like I don't it we'll probably
catch on and it's probably going to be
the biggest thing and I'll look like a
big idiot stuff and that's cool I'm you
know wouldn't be the first time uh but
the the people that are like showing it
off I feel like it's really hard for it
to catch on because you're like you're
like here Alexander put on this headset
and I'm so excited to show you this
thing and share it with you and he puts
the headset on and then he's just like
he's just you know the Oculus face thing
he's doing that and then me and then
let's say you come in too and we're all
like looking at it and we're all like
what are you seeing now ex what are you
seeing what going describe it yeah what
do you and we're all just looking at you
like T let you see what they see yeah
that's true sometimes they will like put
that um have you seen this where they
like
mirror just yeah the two like orbs with
a thing like the wrapped around and it
looks just like that and you're like
what the hell is that like so it's
basically like like watching somebody
just play a video game on TV you can
walk in the room you know what happening
it's like it's kind of a shared
experience and stuff but like coming to
the room and having somebody with like
the virtual reality headset on you're
just like I don't know what they're
doing what are they doing what what is
happening I just I feel so disconnected
from the person that's like in the
virtual reality thing that I'm just like
until it gets to the point where it's
like so cheap that I can be like what's
happening let me put mine on and now
we're in there together we're exploring
a virtual world together now you know
we're like and it's like Yay everybody
in the room has one and it's like we can
all kind of do it together but then it's
like why don't we all just like hang
out why don't we all just like drink a
beer that's like that's like that's like
put your [__] phone down put everyone
put your phone down we're like having
dinner you know it's like the future of
virtual reality is just having orgies
and going to the going to the pub great
H let us know what you think about the
future of virtual reality in the comment
box below everyone all right I want to
keep this going actually I just wanted
to cut that off for the VOD let's keep
let's keep okay so so so one example
we're just kind of we're kind of spaming
virtuality but it's going to take over
and it's going to be huge reality will
be a big thing you know no doubt this
isn't to say it's [__] technology it
won't go any absolutely it will go
somewhere all I'm saying is that I have
a bunch of issues with it right now and
in 5 or 10 years I will think it's an
amazing thing given all of that
development so few people are coming out
and being like okay look this isn't the
super immersive thing that you want but
it's cool in these small ways like just
pay attention to these small assets
these small parts of it that were
getting right uh suspend your disbelief
you're not going to have any feet it's
okay just look up and imagine you're
looking at a strange night sky with two
moons in it wow this is the worst but
like also I mean it's understandable why
they're not doing that cuz that's the
worst way to sell something it's
terrible it's the worst way to you don't
want worst way to be like to be well
cavat caveat caveat I guess it's fine
put this on your face no you got to be
like oh my God you're going to explore
virtual world right one example of
something that I was like yeah I can see
how that's like solving a problem would
be like a a virtual OS you know so
rather than have one my one screen or
having to buy like [__] 10 screens
and spend thousands of dollars I can put
on my headset while I'm programming I
can have programming stuff here I can
have my game over there I can have like
other [__] over here so then it's like
it's a good working environment that
would be way too expensive for me to
actually have you know in the real world
like it's solving a problem I don't care
that I don't have like hands and stuff
because I'm just using it as a really
good headset you know and it's like when
I when I tested the valve stuff like a
year ago I was like there there is no
doubt in my mind that this is the best
headset technology I've ever used oh
really yeah all it did was highlight the
other issues that I still need to get
over there you go well we'll find out in
five years time I can't wait see when
it's going to finally be cool and
affordable uh we've got to get Dave Lang
on in a couple of minutes but uh first
of all uh I just want to have a little
chinwag about what are you going to do
for you've been here since last Thursday
like why do you come to GDC now what is
it about GDC that like makes you get on
the the plane from Melbourne so I was
going to these conferences for several
years as someone who was like Shilling
their game and then talking about their
game which means you just meet thousands
of people and so a conference like GDC
is really great at just drawing like
20,000 people from around the world to
the same location so for me it's just
lots of catching up with friends you
know and and you know maybe showing
things off to people privately until I'm
then back in that mode where I'm like
all right let's do all of the business
deals that I need to do and this year is
just not one of them yeah does a lot of
business deals happen do they happen at
GDC like is it a case where like like an
indie developer from like a you know
sasot sasot Juan is like meeting up with
somebody is that a real place yeah yeah
okay yeah he meeting up with like
somebody from Sony because like oh we're
in the same place at the same time like
do a lot of deals get CAU yeah
absolutely the bus up guys like on both
sides like Publishers and developers
their schedules are just like slammed
just like wall toall especially on the
publisher side cuz like they have money
and everybody wants money and the way
you get money is like you have a meeting
and you talk to people and whatever so
yeah there's um I'm definitely not
jealous of those like is Dev angle
during DDC CU you're just like yeah
you're just wall toall meetings that's
all you're doing is here people beg for
money and what's your ask for money
what's your main uh sort of U uh I guess
goal at GDC this year cuz massive
chalice is a game that's like available
isn't you know feature complete like
it's not totally done but it's close so
I mean we showed it the mix and um we
don't have it at the Expo we probably
should have it at the Expo that would be
smart you just can't be to come to your
office yeah we're so close we're so
close if you want to see it come talk to
me I'm here all week um but I'm giving a
talk about it so that's cool that's sort
of like um it is kind of like a PR thing
as well you know where you're like hey
I'm giving to talk about the game
hopefully there's something in there
like some you know little nuggets of
wisdom if you're making a similar game
um but yeah it's like focused on the
bloodline system and the the aging and
the marriage and the babies and all that
stuff so if you want to learn about that
want to around making babies with BR
mure check it out Thursday uh Thursday
at 5:30 if you're at the show wonderful
and then your your boss is hosting the
GDC Choice Awards as well Tim is hosting
the awards which uh that's tomorrow
yeah he's he's definitely on the every
other uh on the every other plan and uh
yeah he's hosting that thing and he
always writes it I'm probably outing him
by saying this he he is kind of a
procrastinator when it comes to stuff
and he always writes stuff like right at
the deadline but it's always amazingly
hilarious so Simon Carlos was on last
week and he I'm not sure if he said it
on the show or not but I think maybe
said it before we went live but last
year Tim made a flash game about him not
sorry two years ago made a flash game
about him not writing the script in the
time like a week before he was supposed
to be hosting the it's amazing there's
actually two of those I I don't know if
there's a third one that's crazy there
should be um yeah like the host
hostmaster so it's like an adventure
game where you're playing Tim schaer and
you're trying to like write the script
or find the jokes uh before you go on
stage it's really stupid you can you I
think it's still up there on the website
you can.com check it out yeah it's like
there's a bunch of silly flash games
like that on there great there you go uh
we'll be back in a second Mr Dave Langs
waiting in wings uh you're not allow are
you wearing sunglasses no you're wearing
he spent like 5 days in nap transition
lenses is that what they are yeah we'll
get him on in a second uh thanks very
much Jen for for coming on uh we'll be
back in a second H here's a trailer for
umra
he
welcome back to the lobby right here at
GDC 2015 I'm your host Danny DWI Chris
Waters hey Danny on the other side of
the couch oh yeah and look at these fine
gentlemen Brad mure and the one and only
Dy Dave Lang is here so one thing has
changed since the last intro like
Alexander was here yeah yeah you
described that group as handsome yeah he
steps out I step in fine gentlemen yeah
yeah AR gentlemen technically he's
double fine gentlemen so it's kind of Cs
for both of you guys never been mad than
I am right now that's what happens when
you wear an old misc cap onto our show
my friend angry see this can see his
face push camera bunny is it no that one
there you got that one there yeah oh
that is
vicious oh it's serious now no the
transition the transition lenses have
gone oh [__] we got ourselves a
thumbnail call me a fine gentleman thank
you Dave L how you doing my friend I've
never been better welcome to never been
better you spent a couple of days in
Napa I he h please don't ask me to
answer long questions right now okay yes
I was in Nappa for three days we did 14
wineries in three days then we brought
wine back to the house cuz that's smart
yep and oh man yeah right now I'm a my
bu needs to shut down for repairs I
enjoying the clerks in there working
overtime I get their little flesh
wrenches out just fixing me up and flesh
wrenches that's a no I'm into the flesh
wrench I know I've been yeah my whole
body see look at this this is uh this is
footage of the flesh wrench that's
exactly what it's like right there that
was it that was it I just saw that guy's
got another one Nappa Valley legendary
land of the FLH wrench I dare say it was
that was a big group 14 people it was
pretty it was pretty legit Excell it was
the first real original Napa trip right
and we're going to do it again first and
a I didn't get invited I need to become
more famous in order to get invited well
that's not actually the limiting factor
on why you didn't come was this just a
bunch of people who like live in places
where it's snowing all year or all
winter uh I'm not going to dignify that
with a response all right next question
it is pretty cold in Chicago though yeah
how's chitan how's it my wife keeps
sending me pictures looks like it
sucks like snow that's the worst so
she's just hanging out with the kids
yeah she's got three screaming kids
everyone angry in the
house she taking selfies with wine
glasses oh my God yeah she's Prett how
does she put up with it like well she
puts up with you for starters but then
this on top of yeah all right you
definitely got to keep I found the only
person in the planet who hates
themselves more than I hate myself and
who hates you more than you hate
yourself that's why it's like perfect
amazing H I know this is a show about
video games you're wearing your SCA
Ferrari jacket are you excited about the
Formula 1 season returning in two weeks
time uh I'm excited I don't expect
scooter reita have a great year no first
year on the Honda don't see that being a
breakout like they're going to need a
year in the lab the Tinker get it
perfect while you laughing I only asked
this question so I go watch them squirm
yeah I went with the full glaze over
yeah are these cars noo their cars
Alonzo's my favorite driver watching the
car driver he he miss Ferrari gets
concussion
sorry the circles are funny shapes they
drive around funny shaped circles not
just a circle is it too late to start
this over without them oh no we could
just it's the great thing about this is
this is we just yeah we just do this we
just go I'm kind of Trapped and then I
do an intro and then we just cut that
bit out this this is just for live Live
Crew perfect enjoying this Lucky them
actually what I do want to talk to you
guys about is that uh some news came out
earlier that Mad Max the video game
which is not associated with either the
film or the old film or or any sort of
Mad Max play or book or anything that do
associate with Mad Max is coming out uh
September 1st actually same day as migar
solid Grand zero counter programming
exactly so different right
that open open world I have not seen
this yet this is great uh so video game
experts on the couch uh having not seen
this trailer before but they also
announced that they've dropped the
previous gen version so they were
originally going to make a PS3 and Xbox
360 version of this bad boy as well uh I
want to ask you guys as gentlemen who
are part of making games for consoles
and whatnot uh at what stage do you sort
of look at the numbers and go you know
what that previous gen is dead all of
our customers on the new stuff we're not
going to put any more resources into
working on on on those consoles anyway
it's different for something like Mad
Max where you've got like physical Goods
you have to buy and inventory and keep
uh stuff we're doing there's none of
that so yeah if you can keep the dev
cost super low there's no reason not to
be because we don't have cogs right you
CS cost cost of goods yeah what's the
cost of good cogs what is it what's the
cost of what the goods you're referring
to like the massive open world actual
physical stuff thing to get the actual
disc into the store and sell it and then
pay those people and all that and then
store them and ship them and all that
jazz it's like yeah it doesn't make
sense for there's a point where probably
a long time ago it doesn't make sense to
do that wow so that it was a genuine
like even with like the sort of
distribution channels presumably being
there like there is still such a large
cost with getting into I mean like so
say like you know cogs every publisher
has their own terms for cogs but just
say hypothetically they're $5 right on
every game yeah really if you make you
know three print three million you have
to spend 15 million to just to do that
right yeah yeah and if you don't
confident you're not going to make that
back then why you know so it's a it's a
thing it's like a bigger risk yes yeah
yeah also with I think like the the
really big releases and the ones that
that appeal to the hardcore Community
like at this point I guess we're like
two years in know by September we'll be
like two years into the life cycle and
that's like most of the people that
would give a [__] about that kind of
game like a big AAA kind of like thing
they've probably moved on and if you're
going to put it out on the 360 and the
Xbox one it's like I most of the people
if they you know if they're interested
in it they probably have an Xbox One and
they'll buy it there not to derail this
whole discussion I just noticed
something this whole couch pretty strong
sock game like what what's on your socks
you these Sweet Stripes I have s'mores
on my socks sorry sock sorry right the
couch though the couch Denny's letting
us down I'm letting the side down here
mhm sorry the sock game is strong nice
strong these are great well you're yeah
you're AR Vans [__] up [__] up I
know it's vans so my pants so on my
shoes atast dude I'm still young I'm
still young I'm totally not oppos I'll
do a kick flip right now I'm going to oh
wait you've got a skateboard my ankle
straight in your heart
Miss it's how they talking God damn it I
got gray hair I have to look young in
other ways yeah look at my UF shirt
video games video games I don't know
it's like sometimes you just have to
like like the cost of development to
kind of uh like scale everything down
and get it onto the old hardware and
stuff it's just going to cost a bunch
because you're you're trying to like
maximize the current hardware and like
blow it out and just really try to make
it of course with a game like this yeah
you're trying to like just make it look
as [__] sweet as possible and get get
bump maps and spec Maps and get all this
stuff on the dudes and things what's the
difference between a bump and a spec map
I don't know I couldn't tell you that I
knew it I could tell by the
way way you're doing all over face like
saying right now and the bumpiness is
for bumpiness that's kill it we also get
games like Shadow of Mordor right which
its last gen versions had like less
features I mean it wasn't just that the
world was less beautiful or less dingy
as the case may be uh like the Nemesis
system couldn't be as complex on the 360
PS3 version so at that point like is it
diminishing returns on that last last
thing is it like you're not actually
making the game you want to be making
you're making a compromised you don't
want people to have like a significantly
crappier experience on the previous gen
gen platform but there is Lim there
mure mure sound business practices the
doesn't sit on the fence I would prefer
the PS3 version to suck yeah if if we
can have a significantly crappier
version how much crappier how much
crappier can it be that's just going to
Spur them to buy the other one that one
boom to get people to buy PS4s do you
work at
Capcom oh been an adviser for many years
a random publisher everyone yeah sure
yeah yeah you got no beef with them
creator of fighting games oh that's
independent of that oh yeah yeah I got
beef for days right independent of that
you guys are both developers
of games that are released online as
well no you want to get into it you want
to get into it got beef for days just
like that I just like that I just like
that he's got beef for days every got
beef for days he's got beef with me he's
beef with me cuz I didn't go out with
him last night you turn up today old
miss you uh I got a really good old Miss
story but I can't say it on the camera
I'll tell you after okay grace
thanks sorry you were gonna say
something interesting say you're both
very handsome game developers that's
what you're gonna say and here's my
question and your both developers of
games that were released digitally as
well was there was there a sort of time
where the numbers were like okay there
are enough people like comfortable
buying games digitally that we can now
like release things only this way
because I guess it's probably more for
you Dave because like massive chales on
Steam and that's a you know a tried and
tested sort of system by this stage but
like creating an Xbox One game that was
digital only was that ever like a a
worry or anything oh well I fig like the
choice we had to make recently was like
dive kick do we bring it to Xbox One and
PS4 and uh you know that's going to cost
you ahead of time you're like I think
we'll sell this many units I think it'll
cost this much to do it and you just
kind of like make the best educated
guess you can um that's how projections
work too you just go I think we'll sell
this much probably cost this much do you
have like and if this one is bigger than
this one you're like you're like bam
we're doing it this one the weird thing
though is in this business no matter how
that goes you lose money somehow it's
the weirdest thing it's like this one
High last time and now this one's high
and we lost our ass both times I don't
get it at all I maybe it's just not two
variables oh man do you guys have access
to like good numbers for that stuff
absolutely not like Sony don't say we've
got like do you go by MPD actually gamot
and get it's gotten signant
significantly shittier since it went
digital because well yeah cuz it's not
like I mean valve touts big numbers but
they're not like yeah we're just going
to publish all the numbers on everything
that we sell and then the publisher is
like they just you know they kind of
hold on to those digital numbers as well
at least when it was all physical you
could get the npds and they were like
kind of in the ballpark and it sort of
made sense uh that's before I knew kind
of what I was doing though so do you
think they're like intentionally not
like I do now
crap whoops um but like yeah like I I
think that that's how it went sort of
back like in the PS2 days is that the
numbers that you had were a lot more
reliable right like do you think they're
intentionally alting it's I mean it's
not their position to at least those
numbers right that's I mean there's
probably a lot of people that don't want
those numbers getting out period right
so uh yeah it's not really their call
but even as somebody who's like you know
has a partnership with a console
manufacturer saying like we're making
this game for your machine would you
would they not like would you not have a
relationship there where you can be like
look this is how many we've sold this is
how many people bought fighting games in
you know for this console uh I mean that
stuff is useful for pitching for stuff
like if you're proposing like project
like hey we think we want to make a
fighting game and we think the last one
we did in this platform sold this many
the budget of this we can easily recoup
that like that kind of way but it's all
it's it's all firsthand data you know
it's not like you can go to the source
or uh you what I used to email my
friends and say hey what did your game
do on the Wii U or 3DS or whatever right
and then you just Cobble together like
okay here's what a really good like got
comps man you got to get your comps
here's what everyone else did on that
platform which one do you think you're
going to be and then you're like and
then you're like we're going to be like
a shovel KN cuz you're always like yeah
and the reality is like oh no oh what
the reality yeah I mean the reality like
if this is if this is where you think
things are my burst in the reality thing
you said you were as good as you've ever
been I've never been better than I am
now the reality is that Ding committed
to a platform of excellence in all
things at all times okay there you go my
life is one of
Ascension I [__] even know I don't
even know you know I said I was really
good now I'm even better yeah just like
that minute by minute that's how happens
since we started better now it's
incredible bring that thing up again the
destiny one is one of my favorites
because when we were picking like which
ones we're going to show was like oh
yeah Destiny one our our our users would
love to watch lessons from the core
engine architecture of Destiny so
apparently it's just a [__] like
super like top level architecture like
coding talk oh and we're going to have
like all these like kid that's going to
be awesome having like just Destiny fans
just like a 14-year-old Destiny fan
tuning in oh my God and then get horn do
I still haven't got my dead Orit sure
you did the job system right hey and
then it's just like bu John K up there
talking Generations these these
descriptions though half the time
they'll say like like technical prowess
suggested or something like that
there'll be something in there that's
like code for like like listen filthy
casuals not need not apply listen
dummies don't come to this I've had that
so many times I've gone into ones and
it's like oh this is something that's
like as like joural person can sit down
and appreciate and then I've gotone into
other ones and like sat in like the
third row and then realized oh [__] I'm
like so out of my depth and then I just
have to eat it you're just stuck in
there you're just trapped I don't want
to be the [__] that
stands yeah voxel I I I know what that
word is what I do is I fake like I get a
phone call oh really so I'm leaving cuz
the phone call not cuz I don't
understand a GD thing that's happening
it's cuz the phone call it's aort you
just Mumble business to yourself as
you're walk business y
here's what I do I think he's got a call
right now actually talk to
me
unacceptable un sorry I got to take this
that's [__] and you know
it oh my God I hang up and I throw the
phone I gave you your out if you wanted
to storm out uh we're going to wrap it
up there though actually folks uh do you
want to pimp your stuff massive chalice
yeah massive CH so I'm giving a talk
Thursday 5:30 p.m. I don't know the room
number off hand but schedule check it
out and then uh we're going to be out of
Early Access soon and on the Xbox One
probably May June time frame awesome
that's an exclusive oh really Xbox one I
no May June time frame the May June time
frame part you're also going to be
avoiding meiger SOL at 5 grand
zeros TR nobody reviews it yes good
point what' you say said given their
track record if you saying June might be
September first
oo sick burn sick burn it's real talk do
do you not do Early Access anymore huh
do you not do Early Access anymore I've
never done early access really never you
play any other video games except for
your own there's well that implies I
play ours okay which frankly I'm not
comt generous that's
generous Dave ly You' ting to shill
while you're here uh like I said uh
Chelsea blasco's giving a talk on IG
stuff tomorrow that'll be fun if you're
at PAX East we're doing a Killer
Instinct panel all about season 2
goodness you know how do we bring the
rich Universe to life the tapestry yeah
that's weaving the rich in L I see Kats
on Twitter that he's just man he just
loves
agos that's a thing right AOS just
released agos agos some big rock dude
it's a Golem punches guys the The Rock
Johnson is in Killer Instinct it's
amazing all right let's end on that
that's the lobby this week folks thanks
very much for hanging out me or Maya
can't wait for the production team to
chop these into vods that work well this
is going to be fantastic thank you so
much for everyone for coming on
Alexander Bruce who's still here thank
you sir for coming on brir Dave L Chris
Waters great to have you back uh thanks
to everyone in the back for putting
together this show we will see you guys
next week Tuesday 2m Pacific right here
on gamespot.com see you
then
now